two bladesmens
two versions of the same blade
One winner
forged in fire weapons Showdown we are
sending you back to your home Forge to
recreate an iconic weapon from history
that weapon is
a pair of bognock wow
each blade must pass three tests the
strength test the sharpness test the
kill test
good luck blade Smiths
in five days
look look
my name is Josh Prince I started forging
because my younger son wanted me to
forge him a weapon for his action figure
so they forged give miniature sword for
him since then I've moved on to real
blades we're building the bagnak ishwa
two knives actually I want these claws
to be lined up with one another equal
spacing they're actually pretty good the
next step is heat treat a lot of things
can go wrong if it cracks or warps I
start over again
it's pretty straight just beautiful
the rest of it is just fine detail work
the thing I'm most proud of are the
design elements that I put into the
blade the tiger eye Stones bring the
whole thing together as a tiger claw
there's a little scorpion Stinger at the
back too
my name's Chad Hatfield and I'm a
full-time iron worker Ian and I are
working really helps me in the Forge
because we know a bunch of types steel
we work with torches we work with hand
tools all the time so I am going to win
I'm using Damascus because if it comes
down to Aesthetics that might give me an
edge to my competitor I'm liking it
claws are even
it's time to get ready for heat treat
a very straight blade
I'll test it and see if I like it
it's sharp I feel really confident about
these blades I can't wait to see them
being tested
[Music]
foreign
's held up very well there's no mark on
them that they've ever even seen a tree
but I lost your tips
yeah the first one went as I started to
pry but the second tip it cracked as
soon as I stabbed in
I like the feeling of these in my hands
they were comfortable to wield but they
kept deny that they're not there anymore
Chad you're up next you ready yes sir
thank you
[Music]
Munch head
you lost one of your tips
the other one was scaring me but it's in
one piece it held up well I like that
you did Damascus I like the pattern of
it it's really pretty
overall well done thank you
all right Josh these are Sharp you can
see these cuts
clean rakes across the chest no tearing
I actually like that hook you've got
these are definitely Cutters nicely done
thank you all right Chad you're up you
ready yes sir
[Music]
all right Chad these are amazingly sharp
each one of those cuts is beautiful and
clean
they're very light very fast I think he
did a beautiful job these are very nice
weapons thank you
[Music]
foreign
first up it's comfortable my three
fingers in the middle allow me to grasp
on to the claws easily and not feel that
it's going to impede my movement with
the hand the clawing is very deep your
slashes cut deep into this big carcass
overall your bag
will kill good job thank you all right
Chad your turn you ready yes sir
thank you
all right Chad first up the handle it's
on the thinner side there's a little bit
of movement there but the positions
where you have the claw is secure it's
safe they're razor sharp on the
lacerations there the slicing it cuts
deeply overall your weapon will kill
thank you bladesmiths
both of you have put in an incredible
amount of work unfortunately in this
Arena of competition there can only be
one forest and fire champion
congratulations you are a new Fortune
fire Champion good job Josh
unfortunately your bognoc did not make
the cut Josh if you brought us a matched
pair of beautiful knives but
unfortunately in the strength test yours
took more damage and that's why I have
to let you go I understand Josh please
surrender your weapons
I'm a little discouraged or disappointed
but uh I'll bounce back I'm really proud
to make it this far to me as real
acknowledgment that I have a skill set
for this that I'm going to keep pursuing
it keep getting better learn from my
mistakes Chad congratulations you are
the new forged and fire champion and
that's a title that comes with a check
for how much ten thousand that's right
ten thousand dollars good job please
present your weapons to the judges I'm
feeling really good right now
reinforgeous fire champion of surreal I
was able to show my best and it makes me
feel really proud
forged in fire weapon Showdown